[Music]
it's been decades since the original
knight rider was on the air and without
kit david hasselhoff and most of the
actors who played friends and foes have
moved on with their lives
let's see where their careers have taken
them the end of the original night rider
series didn't end david hasselhoff's
time on television
after fighting injustice with kit
hasselhoff got the leading role of
lifeguard mitch buchanan on baywatch
which ran for an impressive 11 years
along with numerous film and tv projects
he reprised the role of michael knight
in the 1991 tv movie knight rider 2000
returned to his brief role as snapper
foster and the young and the restless
and played marvel super spy nick fury in
the 1998 tv movie nick fury agent of
shield
in the 21st century hasselhoff's acting
work became increasingly
self-referential with hasselhoff often
appearing
as himself in otherwise fictitious tv
shows and films
easier for you to say he appeared as
himself in episodes of the west wing and
just shoot me he does it on the big
screen too
hasselhoff played himself in piranha 3d
the 2011 comedy hop the 2004 spongebob
squarepants movie and briefly as the
villain ego and guardians of the galaxy
vol 2.
furthermore in 2017 hasselhoff starred
in the action comedy killing hasselhoff
when he's not busy acting hasselhoff
also moonlights as a recording artist
in 2019 he released his 14th album open
your eyes
you won't remember william daniels in
fist fights with bad guys on knight
rider but that's because he filled a
much more important role daniels was the
voice of the smart car kit for all of
the original knight rider series
as well as the 1991 tv movie knight
rider 2000.
before during and after the original run
of knight rider daniels was playing the
role for which he's most fondly
remembered as dr mark craig on the
medical drama saint elsewhere
along with plenty of recurring and
one-off tv and film roles in the
intervening years
the annuals would find a new generation
of fans as cory matthews teacher in the
long-running sitcom boy meets world
he would later reprise the role for the
spin-off series girl meets world
however daniels never completely left
knight rider snarky trance and behind
he voiced kit for two episodes of the
simpsons the lego dimensions video game
and the 2006 comedy the bench warmers
he wasn't often on the action side of
things but knight rider wouldn't have
been the same without edward mulhere
as flaghead devin miles it's devin who
arranges for michael long to be brought
into flag and remade as michael knight
miles and knight don't like each other
very much in the beginning of knight
rider but as the series continues it's
clear the older englishman develops
paternal feelings toward the hero
mulhere's acting career predates knight
rider by about 40 years
among his more memorable classic roles
was captain costanza in the 1965 world
war ii adventure flick von ryan's
express
unfortunately mulhere passed away in
1997 from lung cancer
between the end of knight rider and his
death mulhere played devin miles one
more time in the 1991 tv movie knight
rider 2000.
his final film a comedy called out to
sea came out the year of his passing
rebecca holden played april curtis
kitt's mechanic and flag's lead designer
during knight rider's second season
she took on kind of a motherly role to
the smart car praising kit when the car
performed as it should
and scolding it when it malfunctioned
holden's last appearance was in season
two's penultimate episode let it be me
although april curtis wasn't heard from
again rebecca holden kept her acting
career going
in the late 80s she had one-off spots on
shows like remington steel
night court and a three-episode
recurring role on general hospital in
1987.
her acting since then has been sporadic
but she's still working today in tv and
films
like former co-star david hasselhoff
holden has entertainment aspirations
beyond acting
she started touring with a country band
in 1986 and continued performing and
recording music into the 2010s
with her videos appearing on tnn and cmt
it isn't until knight rider's fourth and
final season that reginald cornelius iii
aka rc3 becomes part of flag's team
played by peter peros
rc3 starts off as a chicago vigilante
scaring off crooks with a fake assault
rifle
after michael knight and kit team up
with rc3 to take down some bank robbers
he's recruited into flag as both a
mechanic and
occasionally night sidekick unlike some
other night rider alumni peros has
enjoyed a lot of regular tv work since
the end of the series
from 1989 to 1991 he was one of the two
leads for the police procedural drama
the new atom12
he also played dr ben harris for 12
years on the soap opera as the world
turns more recently pero stars as
wealthy judge david harrington and tyler
perry's hit soap opera the haves and
have-nots
as you probably already know kilmer had
nothing to do with the 80s version of
knight rider but in the 2008
knight rider tv movie and the subsequent
short lived series it was val kilmer
playing the voice of the artificially
intelligent car kit
after the knight rider remake shuttered
kilmer enjoyed regular work and film and
tv
he plays a vengeful ghost in the 2010
horror the traveler
a fictionalized version of himself in
2012's the fourth dimension
and an officer in the 2017 psychological
crime drama the snowman
kilmer had fans worried in 2015 and 2016
when he abruptly dropped off the radar
for two years kilmer largely denied
rumors that he was battling cancer
in 2017 he opened up about his health
issues with the hollywood reporter
kilmer told thr that he was struggling
with throat cancer he also had a
procedure done on his trachea that made
his voice sound raspy while rendering
him out of breath
thankfully kilmer still seems eager to
work among other upcoming projects he'll
be reprising the role of hotshot pilot
iceman and top gun maverick
if knight rider's kit had a nemesis it
was carr which stood for knight's
automated
roving robot car was the prototype for
what would later become
kits but cars programming cared less
about protecting human life and more
about doing whatever it could to protect
itself
do you wish to drive or shall i
go ahead
the rival vehicle first appears in
season one's trust doesn't rust and is
brought back in season three for the
episode titled kit vs car
while paul pries voiced carr for the
latter appearance it's peter cullen
providing the ruthless car's electronic
voice in season one
he reprised the role for an episode in
the short-lived 2008-2009 knight rider
series
cullen is kept very busy since his short
stints on knight rider
any transformer fans should know his
name cullen has been the voice of
autobot head honcho optimus prime for
decades from the 80s saturday morning
cartoons to michael bay's live-action
films
but cullen's work hardly begins or ends
with transformers
he's done voices for the smurfs teenage
mutant ninja turtles and he was even the
voice of the merciless alien hunter in
1987's predator
and of course who could forget kit not
just the actors who provided his voice
but the car itself
whatever happened to night industries
2000 well as you probably guessed knight
rider needed more than one car to bring
the action and drama to life
in 2017 newsweek looked into what
happened to the different kits from the
series and discovered that there had
been between 14 and 16 different pontiac
trans ams owned by the
studio most of the vehicles were
acquired through a stroke of luck
in 1983 a train transporting pontiac
trans ams derailed
while none of the cars were damaged
california state law deemed none of the
cars could be sold to drivers
general motors sold the cars instead to
knight rider for a dollar apiece with
the stipulation that they would all need
to be destroyed once the show was done
with them
after the series ended the studio rented
a crane and smashed all but five of the
cars with a wrecking ball
a couple of night rider superfans
tracked down the surviving five kits
one is somewhere in the uk while two
were located museums in indiana and
miami the knight riders superfans bought
the remaining two
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one